[MUSIC PLAYING]
NICK PYLYPIW: I'm
Nick Pylypiw, director
of data science at
Cape Fear Collective,
and today I'd like to talk to
you about our racial equity
dashboard.
Cape Fear Collective
is a nonprofit based
in Wilmington, North Carolina.
We're committed to using our
expertise in data science
to support front-line
organizations
in Southeastern North Carolina
in their fight against poverty,
racism, poor health
and education outcomes,
and socioeconomic disparities.
Though we are
primarily an R shop,
we also use Tableau,
ArcGIS, Python, and SQL
in our analytics ecosystem
as we ingest, store, analyze,
and socialize data from a
variety of public and partner
sources.
Our racial equity dashboard
is built in Shiny and ggplot.
The framework houses
tabs as separate modules
for each category
of data stories.
The landing page contains
a brief introduction
to the dashboard itself,
our email address,
and the tab navigation
bar for the data story
categories across the top.
Each of these tabs
follows the same format,
a brief introduction to
the category followed
by two to five
visualizations and stories.
Let's walk through one
of those stories now.
The definition box tells us
that pregnancy-related mortality
ratio, which is
pregnancy-related deaths
per 100,000 live
births is often used
as an indicator of
a nation's health.
The expandable explanation
box gives the viewer
additional context about how to
interpret the visualization.
This plot shows a 30-year
trend of the pregnancy related
mortality ratio
of the US compared
to select economic peers.
Though these five nations began
in the '90s at the same level,
the US has since
deviated from the pack,
nearly tripling its
maternal mortality.
The country is currently
56th in the world.
We often hear of
pregnancy-related complications
due to age.
For White mothers,
this risk becomes
apparent around 35 years old.
In Black mothers, the
increase starts much earlier.
The resulting gap means
Black women aged 40 or older
have a pregnancy-related
mortality ratio
almost four times that
of their White peers.
Educational attainment is
another indicator of disparity.
A college education
appears to correlate
with a lower
pregnancy-related mortality
ratio for a White
woman but has little
to no impact for a Black woman.
Looking specifically
at North Carolina,
we were able to identify a
road map of interventions
based on high-risk
pregnancy factors
and have shared these with
our community partners.
For example, increased access
to prenatal care and pregnancy
testing would have a
significant impact on pregnancy
related mortality ratio.
Over the next
several months, we'll
be aligning our
community data platform
including insights
from this racial equity
dashboard with the statewide
Healthy North Carolina 2030
initiative.
This will allow us to set
attainable, data-driven,
local goals with a focus on
equity and accountability
through shared measurement.
I invite you to explore
the rest of the dashboard
and to visit our website to
learn more about the work
we are doing in the
Cape Fear region.
Please also contact me
if you're interested
in volunteer
opportunities, contributing
to our social impact
investment fund,
or if you just want to
chat about the data.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]